- [Voiceover] We've already
talked about light having
wave-like properties, and the
waves that we're familiar with
in our everyday life we consider to be
disturbances traveling through a medium.
We talked about dropping
a pebble in water,
and the water's a medium,
and we see the wave travel outwards.
We think about sound waves,
which is disturbance in the air.
We think about a wave
traveling through this rope,
the medium there is the rope.
So, in the mid-19th century it
was completely reasonable for
folks to say, "Well look,
light has wave-like properties;
it must be a disturbance
traveling through a medium."
And they said, "Well what
do we call that medium,
even though we don't observe it directly?
Well, let's call it the
luminiferous Ether."
So an obvious question
that was facing folks
who had this reasonable
assumption, they said
"Well, can we somehow detect
the luminiferous Ether?
Can we validate the
luminiferous Ether existing?"
And a key realization is,
is "Well, we must be moving
quite rapidly relative to
the luminiferous Ether."
How do we know that?
Well, we just have to remind
ourselves that, obviously
the Earth is rotating, but
not only is it rotating
on its own axis, but it's
rotating around the sun.
So if this is the sun right
over here, this is the Earth.
The Earth is rotating, and
these are all rough figures,
the Earth is moving around
the Sun at approximately
30 kilometers per second.
30 kilometers per second!
By our everyday standards,
that's quite fast,
but we're not done yet.
'Cuz the Sun is also moving
around the center of the galaxy.
And this isn't an actual
picture of the Milky Way;
obviously we haven't gotten
this far from our own galaxy
to actually get this
type of a vantage point,
but if the Sun were right
over there, the Sun,
estimates are, are moving with
a speed of 200, roughly, 200,
let me write that in a better color so
you can actually see it,
200 kilometers per second.
200 kilometers per second
around the center of the Milky Way,
and then the Milky Way
itself could be moving.
So we don't know our actual,
kind of, our orientation
relative to the Ether, but we are,
we're constantly changing our orientation,
we're moving in these orbital patterns.
If there is some type
of luminiferous Ether,
if there is some type
and I'm just gonna draw
these lines over here
to kind of show our luminiferous Ether,
we must be moving relative to it
if we orient ourselves just the right way.
In fact, the odds of us
being stationary relative to
the Ether are pretty close to zero,
especially if we wait a little.
If we're stationary relative
to the Ether right now,
let's say at this point, since
we're changing our direction,
we're not going to be
stationary relative to
the Ether at that point.
And that's just when you consider
the Earth's orbit around the Sun.
It's even more true
when you think about the
solar system's orbit around
the center of the galaxy,
or even the movement of the galaxy.
So, we should be moving
relative to the Ether,
or the Ether should be
moving relative to us.
So we should be able
to detect some type of,
some type of what's
called an "Ether wind".
'Cuz it should be moving relative...
Ether wind.
Now how would you detect an Ether wind?
Well, let's think about
some other type of medium
moving relative to us.
Let's say that we are
sitting on an island,
let me do this in a better
color for an island.
So let's say that we're
on an island that's in
the middle of a stream.
So these are the shores of the stream.
These are the shores of the stream.
And there is some type of a current.
So the water is moving in that direction.
So that's the medium.
And now let's start a wave
propagating through this.
So if I were to just
take a pebble and drop it
right over here, what would happen?
Well the wave is going to
propagate faster to the left
than it is to the right.
This is from our everyday experience,
and that's because to
the left it's moving,
the medium is also moving to the left.
So as the medium moves,
and then you propagate
through that medium,
you're going to move faster
to the left than to the right.
So the wave is going to
propagate, is going to propagate,
something is going to propagate,
so after a small period of time,
the crest on the right might be there,
but the crest on the left might be there.
So it might look something like this.
And then after another period of time,
it might look something, it'll
look something like this.
So the general point is, for
this little stream example,
you're going to see your
wave propagate faster
in the direction of which
the medium is moving.
So similarly, if you have an Ether wind,
if you have Ether wind and
this luminiferous Ether
is the medium by which
the light propagates,
the light is a disturbance in this medium,
then if this Ether wind has some,
let's say it has some speed,
let's just call it "S".
If you were try to propagate
light in that direction
versus in this direction,
versus in that direction,
it should go faster, we
should notice it going faster
if it's going along the
same direction as the Ether.
'Cuz it's propagating through something
that's also moving relative to us.
And likewise, if it's going
in the opposite direction
of the Ether, even though
it's propagating through
the actual Ether at that same speed,
the Ether is moving in the
other direction, so the light,
based on our 19th century
understanding of the universe,
the light should seem slower.
So you can imagine, people
started to theorize,
"Well, maybe we can measure
light in different directions
and see if, relative to
us, if relative to us,
we see a different velocity for light."
Now the problem was, is that
in the mid-19th century,
light is incredibly fast.
We now know that the speed
of light is approximately
300 thousand kilometers per second.
And in the mid-19th century,
we didn't have good tools
to measure this with a lot of accuracy.
Especially because the Ether wind itself,
even if you say "This is
30 kilometers per second,
maybe we're moving around
the galaxy at, you know,
200 kilometers per second, maybe
300 kilometers per second",
that's still a small fraction
of the actual speed of light.
So if you don't have a lot of
accuracy when you're measuring
the speed of light in these
different directions, and
the Ether wind is so slow
relative to the speed of light,
well, with just traditional
tools in the 19th century,
you're not going to be able to detect
this actual Ether wind, if it existed.
And that's what gets us to the famous
Michelson-Morley Experiment,
because there they didn't
just directly try to measure
the speed of light in
one direction or another,
instead they thought about,
"Let's split some light into
two different directions,
and then recombine them
and see the interference patterns.
And if the different directions
traveled at different speeds
then we'll have different
interference patterns."
And we're going to see
that in the next video.